I'm about to accept a position across
the country after changing the IT field
I work in I've just been accepted for my
first job and in this type of position
with the amount of responsibility I'll
have and I'm not or I'm having some
issues and some have it hesitation zon
if I'll be good enough have you ever
been in a position before where you
tried to bite off more than you can chew
professionally how do you approach it
and is there ever a time where you think
it's best to bow out and quit and if so
how do you know when that point is so
actually most people get hired into
leadership positions they haven't been
in before
The Seagull teams is all about that you
get promoted you do that leadership job
and just as you're getting the hang of
it you get promoted again so there's
nothing abnormal about feeling that you
aren't quite ready for a leadership
position and the reason that some people
fail when they get to these positions
that they're not ready for is because
they're nervous that they're gonna show
that and so they try to hide it they're
afraid to ask questions they're afraid
to say they don't know so they end up
looking scared and stupid hmm which
equates to looking incompetent and I
mean even just with the beloved captain
they they actually kicked off there's a
reason this guy included those
statements in there that he asked
questions and asked for guidance and
admitted his mistakes there's a reason
that he was beloved that is one of the
reasons and so so so that's what you
gotta do is be okay with it don't try
and hide it now to bow out and quit I
have not done that but there's no reason
to because if I don't know how to do
something I have no problem asking for
help up and down the chain of command up
and down the chain of command nothing
wrong with that and I've said this
before that what what you're feeling
person that asks this question
what you're feeling that you weren't
good enough and that you don't want to
blow it those are actually signs of
humility and it's okay those are good I
felt those feelings my whole career and
I still feel them now and when I was in
the SEAL Teams I would over prepare for
things and it wasn't because I thought I
was gonna dominate it was cuz I thought
I was gonna fall short it even I was
telling you I prepared for the podcast
all yesterday I thought I was good
literally had printed out my notes woke
up this morning worked out and I was
like no I'm not ready I over prepare for
this why because in my mind I'm feeling
that I'm gonna blow it
yeah I don't like that bro there's the
thing it's like a for-real thing it's
called impostor syndrome you ever heard
of that no but it's this and I think you
know what I think I think everyone has
it in whether bit or or a lot it's where
you it's basically you feel this you
feel like I'm like on the inside like
I'm really not this good you can be like
champion of the world on the inside
you're like it's just a matter of time
before they find me out you know I don't
know I don't deserve to be here whatever
that I wish more people would have that
because there's a lot of people that I
know that have been leadership positions
that feel that they have the divine
right yeah to be there a lot of times if
they'll have it they'll behave in that
all day yeah but you say you do that's
why they fail that's so rehash as always
bottom line be humble study and learn
what you can ask questions and if you
don't know something admit it now I had
to make this note and I'm cautious to
even say this but I do have to say it
asking questions doesn't just mean
putting your ignorance on clear display
all the time okay when you ask questions
make sure you are asking thoughtful
meaningful questions if in fact if you
can find out the answer on your own do
that if it's something that you can
refer back to and you can look up and
you can
back you can check out the org chart you
can see where that department is or you
can find out who's running that project
without having to ask that question do
that because contrary to popular belief
there actually is in fact such a thing
as a stupid question and you can get
away with it sometimes so you don't need
to be hyper paranoid about it but you
also part of leadership is confidence
and up and down so you gotta have some
confidence and you people have to have
some confidence in you and if if you
don't know anything and you can't figure
it out for you can't figure out some
portions of that on your own that's not
a good sign because I just expect if
you're gonna be in charge of me that you
couldn't look that up you didn't you
didn't review this before you came in
here I know you don't know my job but
you should at least know what the
requirements of my job are you should at
least know what the outcomes at a
strategic level of my job are right you
see what I'm saying there's a difference
so you don't have to go in there and be
overly humble you don't have to go in
there and be overtly blank a wide-open
with what you with what you don't know
mm-hmm because again I was cautious to
make this note because this doesn't I
will you should feel comfortable enough
saying hey I don't know how to do this
or hey can you explain that the way that
works to me can you explain what this
project you know what this project
entails there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that but if
you go into a room and you accidentally
ask a question of something that
everybody legitimately should know
you're gonna look stupid right that's a
mistake that's a mistake
yeah and so don't do that it's okay
be humble ask questions but ask
thoughtful questions meaningful
questions that you don't know because
it's would be pretty difficult for you
to know the answer yeah yeah it's I mean
it kind of seems obvious when you say it
out loud where you're not gonna know
everything know so that makes sense but
bro you got it no song
she's gotta be there for a reason you
can't be like hey I don't know nothing I
shouldn't be hearing and that's another
thing from the beloved captain where he
says for a few days he didn't do
anything
yeah guess what if you can observe for a
few days you're probably gonna answer a
bunch of questions just for the
observation of taking notes and getting
back and maybe conferring with your
trusted agent or your senior enlisted
guy or your your superintendent you can
confer directly with them and keep that
build that relationship yeah while
you're garnering information mm-hmm yeah
don't be that guy try not to yesterday